reviews that are only slurs
this is five chicks we uh let me just
hear you talk hans i'm talking hello
hello
intro hot intro coming up
okay yeah no i thought there was a buzz
but there's not okay cool um
have a good show the buzz is all
in the air for this podcast everyone's
so excited the the air is electric
it's buzzing with energy it's [ __ ]
flammable dude this is like a industrial
hazard i know and we're about to pass
out from all the fumes of how good this
is gonna be
we're definitely gonna live up to that
hype oh yeah okay go ahead hello this is
the intro welcome this is the beginning
and the introduction
okay take two nailed it nailed it no i
like that one i like that one it's
honest hello
what's up what do you think about
ukraine
uh i don't know
a lot about it i'm not gonna lie it
seems like everyone stopped caring about
it yeah it's kind of old news so yeah
get over it all right yeah it's all roe
v wade now it's not like people will be
wait where did you hear about that uh i
just i read the local paper the local
paper that's how i get all my
information i just go down i read uh the
i read the one where it's like hillary
clinton is pregnant by an alien
like national enquirer yeah yeah that's
my main source of news this is the only
one i can trust anymore
you can trust it because you can't trust
it yeah exactly it's a double cross yeah
it's a classic devil well this is
definitely not true so i know that for a
fact yeah the war in ukraine yeah it's
not true it's all hoax it's a false flag
operation yeah it's like birds that's i
that's fair that's not real i feel like
that's something that'd be another way
for mr alex jones to get into this fight
a spotlight just be like ukraine war
isn't real
can you show me it's like any videos
that they've happening and then just
flooded with [ __ ] just being like
yeah there's tanks they're all taping
each other yeah it's crazy it's like the
first like tick-tock war yeah it's
insane it's like i was just scrolling
through reddit and i'm just like that's
a guy getting his eyeball cut out and
i'm just like that's pretty gnarly it's
cool to see white people doing it yeah
[ __ ] white on white violence that's
what we need i feel like that's the one
thing we should take away from this
conflict is that we need more white on
white violence yeah it's more palatable
yeah seriously minorities killing each
other is sad i know
[Laughter]
it's terrible just throw a couple
honkies in the mix and it makes it all
okay it's white privilege yeah it's
white privilege to die in battle
it is your white privilege to die for
your country yeah i can see that how
what do you think about the war in
ukraine besides it not being real do you
think that uh you think that it's gonna
be all russia one day i think that it is
um our fault for creating a aggressive
uh competitive world and we should
create a more relaxed peaceful world
as the world leaders that's way more
serious of an answer than i thought it
was going to be
very diplomatic and very diplomatic
answer yeah
i thought it was just gonna be like oh
they should just like chill
yeah you're not just like i feel like
the world can change at any moment we
can stand up as a universe as a nation
we need to be nicer and we're not nice
and we get not nice enemies because our
enemies are responding to us
but yeah
we're like [ __ ] yeah like we go
around the world and we're like pretty
much
like not big [ __ ]
but like a right a nice sized [ __ ]
yeah i mean we're creating a lot of
strife
um yeah but shouts out troops check out
all the troops love all the troops
shouts out troops russian troops
ukrainian troops all troops in general
north korea
uh south korean troops feuding with
north korean troops did you hear that
they got like mad south north korea got
mad at south korea because they were
just like flying balloons over the dmz
yeah and just like with like sending in
usb flash drives of like
yeah like moonlight and [ __ ] like
yeah
and all that jazz no and like basically
i met your mother that'd be hysterical
if someone was just like dressing like
had a complete uh
uh barney stenson attitude about walking
around in north korea just being like
he's working his way to the top he's
like i'm watching curbed yeah he's like
i'm taking advantage of this regime and
i'm using it to my advantage like that's
a [ __ ] there needs to be a north
korean entrepreneur yeah that's a
documentary i would watch
the man who started from nothing and
became something into nothing yeah like
that's [ __ ] cool i watched that [ __ ]
then the north korean dream
oh yeah dude i feel like the north
korean dream is like
sustenance
and like proper health care yeah just
surviving yeah food that isn't planted
yeah food that isn't plastic in the
window so
but uh
what do you
what what do you watch like during the
day because i'm like i always wonder
like what people who spend their day
watching because i have a very specific
like youtube regimen yeah that i watch a
lot of like it's interesting yeah do you
dive into that yeah
compare algorithms yeah let's compare
let's pull our algorithms out my algo is
more like
a lot of uh
far left youtube videos like hastanabe
and chapo trap house oh okay
and come town
joe rogan clips yeah i get a lot of come
town i get a lot of uh loss
stuff like that nice yeah i like those
guys a lot
um
recently been getting a lot more matt
and shane
just from the podcast standpoint but
who's matt uh matt uh matt mccusker and
shane gillis oh i don't know matt
mccusker that well no he's a
i mean like the one they interviewed
louie
yeah when they they did the episode
where they it was uh shane and matt on
the abs so when they just went through
the presidents
yeah yeah that was fun that [ __ ]
ruled i just i was listening to that at
work and i'm just like i'm learning so
much george washington john adams twice
yeah john adam two times yeah john adams
that john adams
two-term president man first one yeah
look at him
yeah no but like fdr yeah yeah yeah then
him
what the [ __ ] uh no but uh
then a lot of like horror stories and
stuff like that like spooky oh yeah like
the spooky like this person went into an
alleyway and they saw something scary
here's a photo of it
it's not as scary if it's a photo
because you're not in it you're like oh
yeah that's kind of scary i guess oh
yeah i'm not i'm just watching it to be
entertained it ain't like a spooky thing
like i'm not just sitting there like
biting my nails and [ __ ] like that
so you're like
i'm just like playing elden ring
that's like for 45 minutes just being
like oh this is cool so you're listening
to it in the background oh yeah
yeah you can't watch it if you're
playing no yeah do you ever do that do
you play a lot of video games at all i
play uh settlers of catan online yeah
yeah i should play more starcraft too
but i've been playing a lot of catan
it's kind of a problem dude one of my
like one of my buddies in high school
used to just absolutely dominate at
starcraft
and he would come over to my house just
to play it on my computer because he
didn't have it on his computer and like
you would just clock in and just like
sit there for like four and a half five
hours just on my computer while i'm just
sitting in my bed looking at [ __ ]
youtube videos and [ __ ] isn't that crazy
it's a lot of movement you got to be
really fast yeah dude it's like
yeah dude it's [ __ ] it sounds like
you're accounting
like it's counting for your virginity
yeah accounting for your zerg
no but it was it's a [ __ ] it's a it's
a fun game i would say like yeah it's
strategy and it's like you're competing
brainly with your intellect against
another person brain away is a good ad
adjective to describe it thank you
yeah
definitely working brainly i feel like
there's a couple games that get your
brain really going yeah like you ever
play like portal no actually rules
because you can make one and make it pop
out somewhere else and then yeah it's
all like puzzles and stuff like that
nice it's like that brick man or you
have to move the brick to get the guy
out of the house except 3d
yeah yeah kind of like that yeah yeah
that makes sense well i like starcraft
because it's like the future of warfare
so you get to control all these units
and
you're not just one dude shooting
another dude you're controlling a whole
army that's what it's going to divulge
do you think where it's just like just
top down yeah like drones yeah that
[ __ ] i could see that [ __ ] happening
man yeah it's not completely yeah just
[ __ ] clicky clicky clacking imagine
just like generals going from like this
star-studded war like [ __ ] champion
and [ __ ] like that to some dude at a
keyboard it's like 350 pounds just
directing drones and [ __ ] like that and
it's like yeah he's the best at war in
the world you don't want to mess with
him get him behind a keyboard and you're
[ __ ] yeah he just comes in with his
like arthritis
on like he just came from [ __ ]
bowling he's getting bengay on his wrist
yeah just sitting there and like people
are coming by just like feeding him
chicken tenders
sorry he's winning all wars right now
conquer the crimean region yes yeah and
we'll give you all the cheetos and
mountain dew you could ask for he just
has like a hamster wheel of code red i
mean a hamster ball code right just like
that whole coming down
yeah if i can rule himself that's all it
takes that's the life i want to live
this is going to be the future well i
mean i think in the future we're just
gonna have a computer do it all we don't
need a human to control it that's fair i
mean like
no i the thing is i feel like computers
can't like
computers can't account for like just
humans being [ __ ] idiots and humans
like so there'll always be like an
aspect where a human can overcome a
computer because that's not the logical
thing to do
but somehow it works we're just gonna do
something stupid that doesn't make any
sense and the computer's gonna be like
error overload yeah it's just like it
doesn't account for luck
it doesn't account for like people just
being like [ __ ] it i got guns i'm
running in i'm just running it i'm just
like like
and just killing everyone just be like
oh [ __ ] it took one guy just one guy
just basically russians yeah
they're gonna throw bodies at the
problem and the computer's gonna be like
what is the meaning of life yeah it's
like we can't sacrifice all these units
it's like well we can't because we're
making more constantly
everyone's [ __ ] it's pretty much a
cool thing to do yeah so when you came
to now with abortion illegalized i know
we're gonna make so many people to fight
the huns off with
you think the huns are coming yeah you
gotta always keep your eye to the east
like we're [ __ ] mulan
like we gotta light the
like the what's it called the torches
the tires yeah the pyres and then like
some guy just comes up and knocks me
over i'm like now all of america knows
you're here
good [ __ ] movie yeah you remember
that scene very well i know i why it was
my sister's favorite movie so like we
watched the [ __ ] out of it wow and it's
like it's so symbolic because it's like
using technology to defeat
the barbarian hordes
yeah using like gunpowder and like
fireworks and like civilization fighting
against there's civilization
fighting against
brutalization yeah and they're it dude
that was crazy when like i remember
watching it when i was a little kid and
i always got super uncomfortable at the
part when they're like at the end
they're like at the end of singing like
um
one of the songs
and it just cuts to a [ __ ] village on
fire
oh yeah yeah i think when they're
marching through their pass they're like
we're gonna go reinforce the troops yeah
yeah it's like the music stops yeah
something worth fighting for that song
so they weren't fighting and there's
like so they weren't fighting and they
just turned a corner it's like everyone
is dead it's like holy [ __ ] oh my god
this is crazy it really could no it
really captures the emotions of war
where you're like yeah we're gonna do
the little project that we're here for
wait a minute oh god this is a
game of death and destruction and we're
totally un ill-equipped we are just
pawns in this massive game
well that's why we got to support the
troops because they're
that's why they brought in mushu to add
a little bit of cutting
cutting fun because eddie murphy is the
dragon we need more mooshus yeah we need
more mushu we need that at least two
mooshus per troop yeah two mooshus per
troop maybe it's like a fun bunny rabbit
that like is the troops rabbit that has
like a hat on and stuff like that and
then they eat it as soon as they
spend a day in the future as soon as
they like eat mres for the first time
and realize that it's not gluten-free or
vegan yeah just because they've been
drafted from like [ __ ] portland and
[ __ ] like that
they just immediately eat the rabbit
yeah i could see it happening seems like
a pretty good plan everyone has a rabbit
everyone has your emergency meal that's
what they used to do in like the spent
nazis and [ __ ] like that they would like
to get
i think it was like to be a russians but
like special forces you had like a
rabbit or a chicken then you named and
like raised from a baby for like six
months and then like to graduate you
have to shoot it
like the spartans did yeah dude that's
[ __ ] up
yeah i just pretend to shoot the only
thing i'll teach it is play dead the
entire six months
and then i'd shoot next to it and be
like this is the day we trained for
that's smart go ahead be free and i'll
meet you in the wilderness
this is your only job
have you ever had a have you ever had
pets yeah how many
like several i had many goldfish i had a
rat that we took care of in class and
then they're like we're gonna give this
away to somebody and you want it and i
want it and then they grew into being
big and ugly with weird tales they were
like cute little babies yeah man
everything is a cute baby at one point
and then it's just like an adult [ __ ]
rat yeah
it's like a white rat in my house
and then i had a hamster that was just
fat and it just sat there yeah i feel
that about my cat right now i have a cat
that's like 19 pounds and he just like
is like a moving couch pillow do you
feel bad do you feel like maybe you
should get it on the keto diet i mean
like i would love to get it on like
straight joe rogan elk meat diet
but i don't i mean like i i try my best
we give him like as kind of a strict
diet we don't over feed him
so why is it so fat is it the
carbohydrates or the sugar i think it i
think it might be a mixture of
carbohydrates and sugar he drinks a lot
of diet pepsi
are you serious no he doesn't he's a cat
well maybe
no that'd be hysterical if i had to go
to cutie a circle okay just keep getting
a diabetes can he be giving my cat
crystal pepsi
it's his favorite slurping it up daddy i
did catch him eating a like we had pizza
one night and my chick had a pile of
ranch out and he i caught him like
looking at it and i'm just like you're a
fat piece of [ __ ] man yeah he died of an
american teenager yeah you have the diet
of a 12 year old kid in wisconsin that's
eating pizza rolls and ranch on them do
you like ranch are you ranch guy yeah
sure it's good i don't like ranch well
you like blue cheese yeah i like cheese
is good it's really it's i prefer it
over it like because i used to work at a
sandwich shop and i saw how we made
like ranch and it's just like gross it's
like a gallon of mayonnaise half a
gallon of buttermilk seasoning stir
and that's good
that's gross man
were you like were you the type of kid
who'd like dipped his fries in
mayonnaise
sure
would you do that
that's not a good thing wait you need to
fix that about you
that's gross
what's the preferred way to dip your
[ __ ] like ketchup if you have fries it's
all the chip is good yeah i know but you
can't dip it in mayonnaise
that's just bread okay
i hate to be attacking you right now you
know your ideologies and beliefs when it
comes to condiments but i feel like dude
i mean like do you uh
do do you like what do you dip your like
say if you have carrots what do you dip
it in ranch yeah that's fair like i
understand that like i dip it in blue
juice just because i don't like rainbow
i like blue cheese yeah it's good i like
the chunks in it i am a fan of the
chunks chunks are good in blue cheese
it's creamy i know i know especially on
a burger yeah blue cheeseburger that
[ __ ] rules yeah it goes hard it's really
drying
it makes my mouth feel dry sometimes
blue cheese yeah that's great are you
allergic no that'd be sterious if it's
the crumbs not if it has the liquid in
it then it's better oh yeah if you're
just eating blue cheese crumbles then
yeah i can see the dryness coming from
there do you know what i've been doing
recently i'll be making like pasta at
home and i'll put goat cheese on top of
it
goat cheese melts pretty [ __ ] good
dude i don't know if you've had a
premium goat cheese
a lot of pasta yeah it's cheap it's
cheap and it's like easy to make and it
lasts for a minute so like i can just go
home like heat up some pasta go out do
my [ __ ]
like i don't get i don't got like i
basically eat pasta and sandwiches every
day
with the occasional taco and [ __ ] like
that thrown in there
that's cool yeah you know it's phoenix
we doing [ __ ] out there
we having fun well what about the
carnivore diet don't you think healthy
body healthy mind i mean what does the
carnivore diet entail like a lot of
steaks a lot of ribs a lot of chicken
quarters dude i would have heartburn
every [ __ ] day i'm built like an
absolute [ __ ] i can't eat that way dude
if
someone's put a [ __ ] steak in front
of me for like seven days straight my
shits would be insanity it would be nuts
just steak that's [ __ ] ridiculous
well maybe you get used to it maybe your
microbiome would change my microbiome
yeah that sounds like i got like a
jurassic park village in my belly you do
bacteria bacteria i want a brontosaurus
belly you got like the [ __ ] you know
the
pasta destroying
germs and your stuff oh yeah dude pasta
dips one toe into my stomach acid just
ultimate solution
burns up in a [ __ ] millisecond it's
awesome you're like a [ __ ] white boy
that's perfectly designed to consume
white food i know i i like i like me a
good pasta like a good uh like a good uh
like a rigatoni maybe like a like a
penne sauce i'd love me some penne
that's some good [ __ ] not penne sauce
what am i thinking what about
gnocchi key yeah gnocchi
it does sound like something someone
would moan in bed
[Music]
now that's like a pokemon i was gonna
say that sounds like a tamagotchi
that you just did it like some neopet
[ __ ] dude i uh that's my favorite
gnocchi yeah you like that pasta yeah
it's a potato i know it's like it's very
like fun it's fun to swallow
i i like i like texture is good i know
it feels like i'm swallowing like a very
small bug yeah yeah and i enjoy that
i like feeling like a lizard often like
in lion king when he starts eating bugs
i know those are the most appetizing
looking bugs in the entire world i'd eat
the [ __ ] out of those bugs they look
like little pastas i know i want to
slurp them
and i'm just like oh that'd be so
satisfying there's a mouthful of bugs
and then you see one you're like
yeah i wouldn't eat a [ __ ] would you
eat a live worm if it was like good if
it was on the menu
if broken took you out to a dis like a
dinner instead
hey they got harmless no no [ __ ] it's
gonna be harmless but like if
say rogan took you to a dinner what if
it went down my breathing hole
wait that's like trying to [ __ ] with me
well it technically will go down your
breathing it isn't that yeah no i know
what you mean like you swallow it wrong
yeah and it like goes into your
esophagus and you got worm long oh god i
don't think that's a possibility but if
that is i mean you got you got several
other problems if you were if you were
to enjoy worms your life would be so
great because you could just go down to
cabela's or academy or dicks i know
you're just getting like those live
worms just go to petsmart and get
mealworms it's like little snacks just
eating handfuls of worms
man
we're missing something here we need to
prepare and eat worms maybe they're good
maybe they're good they're like jiggly
spaghetti in spaghetti it's already
moving for you yeah just put some tomato
sauce or some white sauce on alfredo
sauce on it that definitely seems like
something you would have in like a
child's halloween walk through where
you're like here is the plate of
spaghetti and whoa
[Music]
feel it it's eyeballs and it's peeled
grapes but there's actually worms yeah
yeah it's actual worms it's actual worms
well yeah i mean we should freak kids
out more they need to be aware of the
world that we live in
dude that'd be hysterical if you had a
haunted house that was just like real
scary things in the world
your mom dying because she doesn't have
health care yeah like the atrocities of
war
and life and it's like the thought of
having like family members that owned
slaves and [ __ ] like that you're just
like oh god you're just running through
it's just like did you know that we're
bad it's like
yeah you just it's just a guilt scary
house this is a guilty guilt black
people are living in the ghetto as we
speak yeah how much do you pay for rent
half of that would feed this whole
family right here and you're just like
huh
and then at the end at the beginning
instead of taking like ticket prices
just called reparations and you just
give them like 15 bucks and they're just
like that's it and then you go in
it's just a whole just guilt-filled
nightmare yeah
your clothes come from this poor
indonesian child sleeping away
yeah
you just get to choose which like
what uh branded jeans you're wearing and
then you just press the button and opens
a different door and shows you the
sweatshop like oh you thought h m was
good oh contraire
you thought those pleated denim pants
were nice oh well they're made by a
child
this haunted house is the ghetto that uh
your suburbs created through suburban
sprawl and white flight yeah why don't
we uh go back in time to see the local
restaurants that were owned by minority
business owners
before your area was gentrified with
honkies like you
just be like that starbucks that was a
building that was there for 45 years
just walked through like oh my god this
place was full of life and culture yeah
just be like oh do you know that small
business owner do you wanna know where
she is and then you go and it's a
graveyard and you're just like oh my god
and then at the biggest tombstone the
american dream
you gotta be asleep all snaps
all snaps no caps oh snap no cap
i can imagine a poetry slam doing that
[ __ ]
it's all
current with the lingo oh yeah they're
so current with the lingo i think it was
just so current nowadays it's hard to
keep up yeah it's like a goddamn
electrical wire how current it is they
should make a current
like a current thesaurus to where you
can see like
like slang term synonyms and like
antonyms and stuff like that yeah it's
like cap what does cap mean cap is lying
like no cap i'm not lying
to him sentiment synonym uh
on god
no that'd be out of pocket out of pocket
yeah that means you are lying
please refer to [ __ ]
i love that it's like urban dictionary
trying to widify the black experience
and trying to make it official and try
to trying to understand and
scientifically break it down but yeah
then you sell it and then you sell it as
a coffee table book at urban outfitters
and make millions yeah that's a good
idea i mean listen there's so there's so
many the the
market for selling to dumb white people
is growing
more and more every day
like you can just make like some like
[ __ ] uh essential oil treatment
that's like it's oh it's a meditation
enhancer put it on your hands and
meditate and they'll be like this really
works it's like yeah because it has like
tingly oil in it
tingly oils yeah they just got and you
got 55 bucks a bottle when you're paying
three
yeah per unit it's just like it's
people people just buy [ __ ] now man yeah
that's how we feel good about ourselves
this consumer
yeah people get like people get [ __ ]
like like some like box sent to their
house every month of random [ __ ]
that they mostly throw out and they just
completely forget about and then they
get like an extra like 150 200 bucks
from the company it was like give it to
them just because they're like oh [ __ ] i
forgot to cancel this now i have seven
new shirts or like a box of steak and
unlimited bacon because i signed up for
that in 2012 when it was cool
do you remember the whole bacon phase
yeah that was [ __ ] that big meal time
oh my god what happened to those guys
they uh
i think they turned into like uh
i think they
they
they were living in too much luxury and
too much
you know they just got too big and they
just imploded it's just some stars burn
too bright yeah you know you can never
fix that
the cholesterol in their
bloodstream yeah for like i mean it was
that was back in like the golden days of
youtube when like the formula was simple
where you just go and spend three
hundred dollars and just [ __ ] up a
mcdonald's for an hour and a half and
then you go home make it into a lasagna
and get a [ __ ] million bucks from it
it's crazy like when like monetization
first came out
it was only based off like views and
[ __ ] like that and it wasn't like under
this kind of like
strict diatribe of like oh like you have
to do this you can't curse within the
first 10 minutes of your thing blah blah
blah blah blah blah
it's like now like back then it was just
like you get 15 you get 15 000 views per
thing here's money
and now that turned into like all these
people being like oh yeah i make youtube
videos and i just bought a five million
dollar mansion and now they're just like
i just sold that mansion for twenty five
hundred thousand like two hundred fifty
thousand dollars that's a good video the
sadness oh yeah just the where are they
now yeah and [ __ ] like that like uh when
they do that with a basketball players
just talking about how much money they
lost
it's being like all right i lost about
500 dollars in vegas one time and
they're just like oh my god yeah it's
like a whole life
it's like a life's worth of money yeah
that's generational wealth yeah dude
it's crazy what do you think of
generational wealth would you like to
get there yeah i mean i think everyone
aspires to it but there's a lot of i
think our species has generational
wealth and we just need to spread it
around evenly and equally
very true very true that's good point i
feel like it's a very socialist point
i mean is the socialist or communist
where you just share wealth evenly
um i have no clue i don't know i don't i
don't think that it should just be
completely like divided by the
population but i think like the total
net worth divided by population but i
think like you should get a minimum
amount so that you're not coerced into
working yeah coe i completely understand
that like a basically like
base set minimum wage for just people
yeah just to exist and like have and you
would like want to have like
housing that would be able to
accommodate the people within that set
wage yeah and stuff like that but like
even with
even with that it's like sometimes
thinking about that it gets a little
spooky just because it's like you're
gonna build these giant things where
it's just like everyone's gonna be
living there it's like well
what's gonna happen like where are
people gonna actively like try to
like lubricate the economy around them
and like support it get jobs put money
into it get money from it or are they
just gonna like sit inside which is a
completely valid option that you could
do but you wouldn't have the best life
in the world
yeah i don't think anyone would be happy
doing that yeah it really it would
depend on like the mindset of people
which i feel like the government
wouldn't want to do that because they
think everyone's a [ __ ] idiot
and like for the most part some people
are really [ __ ] dumb
yeah i mean i think there
are a lot of dumb people because like we
have a system that doesn't really reward
people
yeah no so they're not incentivized to
better themselves they're just
incentivized to like show up and you
know punch a clock and flip burgers and
then go home so yeah yeah you're gonna
be stupid your incentive is eventually
to retire in like what 45 years like it
sucks that there's might be poor people
who are just sitting around jerking off
and scratching their balls but i think
even worse is if there's one person
that's taking all the
money and wealth and
you know uh
work that people are doing and then
siphoning it off and living in yachts
and not doing anything
yeah just absolutely just
completely just greed hounding yeah i'd
rather have poor people doing nothing
and siphoning away from the system than
like a rich person separating away way
more efficiently and effectively yeah i
mean like that's understandable but at
the same perspective like you would say
that to a rich person and they would be
like no i've earned my position and that
is maybe like
15 10
i would say like there's it seems like
generational wealth is something that is
like very much so accumulated nowadays
where they just are born into money
they're gonna die with money and like as
long as they don't epically [ __ ] it up
everything is going to be okay for them
when there's like self-made millionaires
and people who came like within our
industry for instance like people who
started off just doing open mics and
then eventually through it became
successful into the entertainment
industry like you're doing that right
now you're [ __ ] doing great yeah and
like i mean i'm trying to do my best and
like i don't have any [ __ ]
like diamonds behind my name or anything
like that like you used to live in a
[ __ ] van exactly like it's it's it's
all the perspective that it comes from
because if you're born with like a
[ __ ] ivory spoon in your mouth you're
gonna have a different perspective on
someone who like can't get out of like a
certain financial situation that then
impedes on a mental situation because
it's like that reacts your brain that
you can't afford something that other
people can afford and you see all this
wealth around you and you get resentful
yeah and like it's not like a cohesive
like oh i want to do this and like start
anew and like oh this is going to
motivate me to do more it's like no when
the walls are crushing in on you you
feel that to the utmost extent and it's
like there's no solution there's not a
solution present for you you just have
to take it yeah that doesn't engender
hard work yeah it doesn't the pull
yourself up by your bootstraps
generation is
far long and gone it's not it's not here
anymore yeah if you work hard you're
just going to get exploited into working
for a corporation that's going to pay
you minimum wage and then fire you as
soon as they find a cheaper alternative
yeah it's there's no
like if the whole pull yourself up by
your bootstraps it comes with the
implication of it being like the
the bootstraps that you got from your
company
it's not your own boots that you've made
by hand if that was more like implicated
to whereas like you pull yourself up by
your by your own beliefs like if you
want to do something like you want to be
a carpenter you want to start your own
[ __ ] sewage business if you like
[ __ ] power washing front driveways
like yeah but it's not easy for you to
start your own company because there's
already companies that exist that make
it difficult for any competitors i know
it to exist it's a it's a [ __ ] it's a
two-sided snake you're just constantly
eating yourself
it doesn't it doesn't work out and
like we were talking the other day about
the anti-work subreddit
and like i i understand it but even like
when you scroll through it you're just
kind of like there's some that are like
you're just kind of being a [ __ ]
and then some of them are just like oh
yeah you can't go to your mom's funeral
because i need you to serve and it's
like yeah you can go [ __ ] yourself like
yeah it's great like there's no
financial value to you going to your
mom's funeral yeah there's nothing that
can benefit me there yeah so
all your life should be worked towards
uh converting your energy to
money that someone else can take from
you yeah that is being paid off in like
taxes that are a significantly larger
lump sum of your money than it is
someone who is far wealthier than you
yeah it's like and even if then like if
they
don't have their like money and like non
like profit [ __ ] that can't be taxed
like people do that a [ __ ] ton
so it's just constantly people gaining
the system
and
everyone else on the bottom floor just
having to deal with the wild parties
going up above them [ __ ] hitting
broomsticks against it and they're not
going to stop
yeah it's it's it's a it's weird it's
weird to like kind of go through your
entire
elementary school to adulthood life like
going through your like
k through 18s being like i can build
something of myself and then kind of get
into the world just be like people are
at a higher pivotal
like advantage from me by just doing
nothing yeah and i can tell and you have
to overcome that and people sometimes
don't even value that
because they're in the position already
and they're just like well i'm here why
aren't you here it's like [ __ ] i
didn't start there yeah success is the
only metric yeah it's it
all people sees like it's like all
people see are like the likes on
instagram yeah and stuff like that they
see the fancy stuff they see like the
glitz the glamour
like
nobody
really considers more the work of it but
at the same time is there like some
people are just privileged to the point
where like
it's like oh you're being sponsored by
like an energy drink company take a
photo of you holding this energy drink
we're gonna give you like 15 000
and it's like if you gave that to
someone in like just like literally just
walk down through like if you stayed at
a [ __ ] hotel and just gave that to
your like maid or something like that
coming in that would change their entire
[ __ ] like three years it would change
their entire life you're just being like
hey i like mixed berry blast
buy it all right here you go it's like
it means nothing but at the same time
people have like this kind of like
like this beaver kind of
way of thinking where they need to pile
on and build this dam of wealth and [ __ ]
like that and it's like at the end of
the day you're sitting on this mile hall
mile high wall just being like look look
at all the money i've accumulated
all right now it's time to die
it's like what the [ __ ] is the point
yeah if you're not doing it for the good
of society and if you're just selfishly
accruing wealth it doesn't make you feel
good no it's like
you can just watch the number go up all
you want but it's like at some point you
should just like
you should just do something to help
[ __ ] someone man
yeah
i mean i think that we that's our
purpose is to be a part of society and
to help society and if we're not doing
that it makes us feel really bad
um and i think like we have this
mentality of uh
you know trying to
beat everyone else but i think that's a
short-sighted goal i think we should be
working to help everyone else get better
and
uh it just takes a shift in
consciousness to be like oh that's an
empty goal how many how many times do we
have to hear that story of someone being
super wealthy and not happy before like
okay so what's the answer money is not
the answer so
let's go move on to the higher maslow's
hierarchy of needs yeah it's like so
when you get to that point in said story
when it's like oh money can't fix this
it's like wouldn't you have liked to
understand that before the money
that you
have inner deeper issues that aren't
just
associated with you not having enough
wealth
to where you actually when you do
have funds and stuff like that in your
mentally better place wouldn't you want
like you'd want to help people you would
want to help out the people around you
who you care about at least that's what
i would think at least like within like
kind of like my own mental faculties
like i would definitely go out just kind
of just be be a big tipper just make
someone's day tip them see if i got made
three thousand bucks that day just doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] doing nothing just like
i'll give a thousand away [ __ ] it who
cares it's like i don't know what i
believe in like kind of like
ideologically like when it comes to like
religion
and stuff like that more agnostic than
anything but i more believe in karma
where if you put good in you're gonna
get good out yeah when you put good into
your society you're gonna live in a
better society with less poverty and
less homelessness yeah it's it's it's
all what you put into it and i feel like
a lot of people
kind of get into
the idea of oh once i uh once i get here
then i'll start helping people
and it's like you can start small yeah
you can help people if you don't
practice helping people then you're not
going to be good at it yeah it's not
it's all about like it's not about the
man you are at the end of the day it's
the main you've grown to be like all
throughout like say if all of a sudden
like hitler became a huge humanitarian
at the end of it and just being like all
right while he did kill all those people
he also started a thousand puppy farms
like it was like it it's no it wouldn't
matter man it's like you have to
accumulate
good karma throughout your entire life
and if you do that you'll be more having
a better ability to help like if you
just start helping in the middle
of your evil regime then you won't have
that
positive ability or that ability to do
positive things you won't be practiced
at it you won't know how to do it yeah
you won't have like the kind of
like the you won't have the basis of it
like you're be building a house on a
weak foundation just because you're
throwing all this philanthropy and
helping and all of this non-profit
fundraising all this stuff onto just you
coming from just
like
over exuberance like greed and stuff
like that and it's it it doesn't it
doesn't cooperate it doesn't you that's
not something you can just switch on you
need to like kind of grow and be better
naturally
and i feel like it just comes with step
by step and there's like oh there's
pivotal moments where you can take like
it's a fork in a road right it's like
you can do this and like that doesn't
help you and it's not the greatest but
it like it helps you more and it's not
the greatest but you could take less
help and help someone else with you and
sometimes you take the [ __ ] selfish
route and that's that's not we're humans
we do that we look out for ourselves
primarily first and that's just a
natural thing
but
we
like whenever you take that roadless
like the
selfish road you look back and see the
other one you're just like [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] i feel like even if you can't
succeed with the evil route like you're
still only succeeding being evil like
yeah it's like not the best option but
if you succeed doing good then you get
to do good and succeed that's obviously
the best of both worlds oh god
water went down the wrong hole oh no
worm it's a word
i got worms in my mouth i got worms in
my lungs so uh what do you think about
uh amber heard and johnny depp
um
i think it's interesting as [ __ ]
i think it's very interesting i think
well they're two unique people they're
very
oh my god
ah i have coke
i have ebola i apologize you got
liquid on your uh breathing holes oh
yeah i have liquid all over my breathing
holes right now i'm just trying to like
[ __ ] white knuckle through it and not
peek into the microphone just
uh get rid of all that moisture with air
and just like
huck it out
just aerate yeah
i'm good
well that's the one i needed
there's a lot of like in cells that are
like see women are evil this is why i
don't get laid i think that's a very
dumb and staunch point to make they
think that like this one person is the
mascot for all women yeah i think she's
a [ __ ] nutcase she's very unique i
mean i don't know if that's who takes a
poop in someone's bed
yeah
have you ever been like to that level of
furious to where like that was an avenue
in your brain that you thought was
reasonable
i've never [ __ ] in someone's bed before
i've never [ __ ] outside of a toy no i
[ __ ] my pants a couple times
so that that's me admitting my own fault
but i didn't do it as a statement uh
yeah i didn't i wasn't sitting there at
a chick-fil-a demanding extra sauce and
when they said no i [ __ ] my pants out of
protest no it was as instinctive it was
like very spur-of-the-moment type of
action yeah that's uh but that being
said [ __ ]
it's an alpha move
it's crazy that that's the level that it
taps into like she wants to do something
guttural and something like priming how
evil you are to me yeah i'm a cr you've
made me into a creature into an animal
and i poop the bed i don't poop inside
the bed on top of the bed that's a
probably better way to poop i was about
to say squatting i was about to say she
pooped in the bed that would have been
worse in my eyes because it's more sheet
cleanup
actually no you probably got it if
someone took a [ __ ] on my top sheet i
would probably get rid of all the sheets
i wouldn't i wouldn't just be like oh
it's one layer deep no that's a
that takes it i'd probably i'll look at
my seepage i probably look at the
mattress as well
yeah i mean she's like uh out of control
and she's like so much ego and like she
she wants to control things yeah dude
she's had that like pretty much for like
the past what like 15 years yeah
everything like she has assistance she
has all this all that like every day is
her she's living the amber heard show in
her own [ __ ] mind yeah but i think
like she has this false idea of how much
power someone should have and what's the
best use of it and i don't think it's
her oh yeah absolutely i mean like it's
not her fault
that's what we tell people she
definitely doesn't help it
it's like it's not her fault but at the
same time
there are avenues that she could take
where
things would be less
kind of catastrophic interactions yeah
it's like i don't think you had to
exactly like chop the guy's finger tip
off
or anything like that but at the same
time you know pick a poison what do you
want you want a crazy hot lady or you
just want some run-of-the-mill chick who
won't take a [ __ ] in your bed
yeah i mean if you want a hot chick
she's gonna be like well i could have
anyone i want so i'm gonna have to make
this worth my time yeah what a lot of
people don't understand with hot chicks
is that hot chicks have been hot for a
very long time it's not like suddenly
they were hit with like a like
tinkerbell
like suddenly you're the belle of the
ball like no they've grown up with that
hot chick attitude they want it all yeah
they're like i'm not just happy having
the hot chick thing yeah i want to be
the best each one of them is like
britney the conqueror like they want
they want to pillage and take like it's
there's no there's no if ands or buts
about it
and so when you run into them it's just
like hitting them with a no
is absolutely
shattering minds yeah she's hot she
needs everything yeah otherwise there's
another hot girl getting something or
the thought to be denied
like say if some chick was like at a
club i'm sure like this has happened to
you like i i have a
i have a girlfriend and stuff like that
and i've been at comedy clubs and i've
had chicks come up to me and like kind
of like hey what's up and i'm just like
oh i have a lady and they're just like
and they immediately just go into like
like completely like frozen just like no
that's
not even what i'm talking about like oh
my god like i'm just like obviously
backtracking it's like not used to
rejection oh yeah and just completely
just [ __ ] crab swirling just [ __ ]
like error this is not supposed to
happen i'm supposed to reject that 404
page not found yeah like i thought i was
going to softball a nice beach to this
weirdo but it said he shot me down and
now i have to go [ __ ] something yeah to
feel like i'm hot again
now you're welcome to our world yeah
welcome welcome to the pit i realize
that i don't have any defense against
women
really because completely defenseless
yeah cause like my i'm not used to women
wanting me
uh and i'm saying to women
uh
being repulsed by me just by just being
me being me
so yeah like now like if a woman comes
up to me and
she's like flirting with me in a
situation where i don't want to be
flirted with i'm just like i i don't
know what to do like i'm doing what i
usually do to reject or to have women
reject me and it's not working i've had
like people take like i'm pretty sure
you've had this too because you've done
a lot of shows and there's drunk women
are
honestly like the most sexually
aggressive
creature
in the world because they don't have
that uh
voice in their head being like don't be
a creep don't be a predator don't be a
rapist yeah that's in our heads all the
time there's not a ticket like it to
catch a predator episode where they're
inviting people to catch a brittany yeah
to catch a britney where they're
inviting like all these chicks into a
varsity [ __ ] high school locker rooms
and [ __ ] like that just being like why
are you trying to meet trent today like
no that doesn't [ __ ] happen yeah why
are you trying to hump yeah this man do
you know colton's 16 years old
he's like that was a penis of a man he's
like i know
you're going to jail
no but [ __ ] it's just like so they
need to go to gay bars
dude i've had chicks like taking [ __ ]
swinging glances at kissing me and [ __ ]
like that after shows after i've done
jokes about me having a girlfriend at
the show and i'm just like it's like i
want him i'm gonna get him yeah i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm like do
you know i'm like i like literally have
stopped people and like you know if
you're if i was doing this to you it's a
crime right yeah i'm like you know if i
was doing the same [ __ ] to you right now
it'd be a crime
and she would be like oh my god you're
stupid i'm like i don't like this this
is a crime stop
in there and just be like you're so
weird i'm like well this makes me
uncomfortable yeah they have no defenses
against their horniness because their
horniness is like sought after and
they're used to like keeping it hidden
oh yeah people don't oh yeah the
treasure chest is open and you're
ignoring the gold because you have a
better treasure at home
and it's like i don't want your 15
doubloons miss
i got pearl necklaces and gold skulls
back at my place man i'm gonna give a
[ __ ]
that's just crazy like have you had any
like chicks coming up to you for trying
to [ __ ] with you at shows and [ __ ] like
that
not really not really
yeah not that you're a handsome guy
thanks tristan you're a handsome guy i
saw you last night karaoke with your
shirt unbuttoned you got a little you
got a little chest built bro you got a
little chesty room well i hang out with
my girlfriend and uh we have a good time
i mean your girlfriend's a very good
singer yeah she's really talented i
loved watching you watch her sing it was
hysterical
you're just like in that moment you were
the girlfriend in the crowd watching her
boyfriend play in the band you're
[Music]
that's awesome i'm so cute
you are very adorable
you are very adorable like a little
child i was pretty drunk too yeah it was
very funny the song that you chose yeah
i love i loved it i loved it i thought
it so basically if i can explain it if
it's not too flagrant you we did a
karaoke bar last night and um
hans went on did nwas uh [ __ ] the police
but every n-word was replaced with
neighbor
and you the thing is you just [ __ ]
like you did it 19 times in the mirror
flowed perfectly through it with
everything and everyone was just
laughing so hard every time you got to
it but the thing is no one expected you
to say neighbor when the first n word
came through so everyone just heard an
er and just turned around
we're like oh my god i'm like oh he's
saying neighbor he's saying neighbor
he's saying neighbor
neighbor we're good yeah this is tumblr
approved we're good it's like uh
audio illusion you just hear what you
want to hear yeah i know what you think
is gonna happen yeah is this brittany or
whitney
it's the audio version of like the green
and uh no the blue and gold in the white
and gold no blue and black and white and
gold dress you remember that way back
when when it was the photo of the black
and blue and the white and gold dress
and people were seeing like different
ones and everyone was like breaking
their [ __ ] brain over it
it was like a big that was back in like
2016 when [ __ ] like that could be news
and now it's just like everyone's dead
[Laughter]
yeah there's less hope in the world
we're a sad society yeah man what the
[ __ ] happened do you remember when obama
was around 2008 well trump became
president and then we were like oh i
guess
we're going full [ __ ] and like yeah
we're just gonna double down on a lot
we're gonna [ __ ] kick flip into
oblivion and just absolutely fall into
the abyss
yeah it just became dumber and like less
um
less hopeful it's just like we're just
gonna get really good at uh being
selfish and that's not a very
uh logically hopeful place oh yeah like
selfishness uh i don't know people know
only helps one person
it's it's really in the grand scheme of
things not helpful to the unit well we'd
like to think that it helps everyone
everyone being selfish helps the society
function yeah they're like i'm selfish
now to help other people later but maybe
it's just you being selfish yes you want
to be selfish and you're just saying it
helps everyone because
that'd be sad if it didn't and yeah and
even when you help people it's for
selfish reasons it's like oh i helped
them because eventually i support this
and then it works so
why be helping at all just if you're
going to be selfish just be really good
at being selfish all the time yeah and
it creates a society where everyone's
pecking at each other yeah and that's
how you become a president
it's just like we emphasize the wrong
things about ourselves i think and then
we're like what is the point of all this
what is the future and it's like we
don't really see an answer logically so
we have to go into our emotions and not
think and that's the only way we can be
happy is to like mumble rap
oh i did trust me i feel that see my
that's my only escape is the 808s okay
808. it's drumbeat tornado at 808's and
heartbreak that's all i look forward to
no but i mean like if i could just bring
myself back to the age of just listen i
mean like even then like just listening
to skrillex and playing call of duty
modern warfare when i was like new if i
could bring myself back to that i would
but at the same time it's like all the
bad [ __ ] is still going on i just don't
know about it
it's like all these terrible things are
going on and this is completely
oblivious to me cause i'm worried about
algebra well it's better that you don't
know about it then you know about it and
you're like i don't care i'm gonna keep
doing that yeah that's fair and honestly
as like a 12 year old there's not much
you can do
politically well you're geopolitically i
feel like you feel the society that
you're in very well and you respond to
it and you're a very sensitive guy and
then you understand how it affects you
emotionally and then you play off of it
yeah i think you're very strong
personality and you talked about me
right now energy yeah oh thanks man
that's really nice yeah i thought i
thought you were talking about no thanks
man yeah i think you're very now it's my
turn to suck your dick uh i think that
you're very smart i think that you're
very uh
uh eloquent in your answers and it's
very easy to have a very interesting
conversation with you so it's a lot of
fun i don't like being here yeah the
fans provide the fancy balls the fancy
balls of ice yeah
we got the spherical ice cubes i know i
busted through that [ __ ] teeter soda
in two seconds cedar seven up taters
peters [ __ ] just for skeeters
shout out teeters so what do you think
about the uh general state of our
culture and how we haven't had a good
comedy movie in a long time isn't that
[ __ ] nuts how we haven't had a good
honestly i thought
the best attempt at it was the new
jackass movie
there is a few moments in the bet
there's a few moments in that that
really just [ __ ] got me like did you
see it no
oh dude it is so funny i'm waiting for
it to come out online it is it's
streaming it's already streaming i'll
check it out i wanted i wanted to watch
it for free yeah no you can watch it for
free for sure no but it's like there's
this one sketch in it where they
basically like the whole prank is they
have like
like four sets of two people in a room
and they basically are
pulling a prank and a fake prank so they
have like this rattlesnake that isn't a
real rattlesnake and they like show it
to them and then he gets the box and
they replace it with a different box
that just has like the sound of a
rattlesnake in it and then they turn all
the lights off and knock the box over
and then they're just uh johnny
knoxville and a couple of other guys are
just in there with night vision goggles
and like have like trash can lids and
[ __ ] like that and stuff to [ __ ] with
them and so they're just sitting there
in pitch blackness like huddled up in a
corner and johnny knox will come up and
just like slap their head together like
symbols with the trash can lit so
they're just like
like
it just like they'll come with the
kettlebell just be like buzz
it just completely flip [ __ ] it's like
the most psychologically torturous thing
but it's like next level funny it is so
good and when they painted a wall to
look like a to look like a pathway to a
ramp and he just ran right into it and
splat it against it like a cartoon that
ruled that's some classic looney tune
[ __ ] that i love right there that's some
good comedy i guess we do make good
comedies
um but uh like our movies are just
remakes of marvel movies and none of the
movies that right now have people
wearing masks in it like that is true
pre-covet like they don't want to date
it it's like pre-covered or post-covered
oh yeah
yeah it's like i'll pre-covet or
directly pass covet or coven never
happened
i don't think they're gonna bring covet
into the mcu
yeah one of the superheroes been able to
do something about it they're powerless
against microbes yeah for real like
[ __ ] green goblin
put out like some disease and [ __ ] like
that and it spreads across the world
unfortunately batman died of covid
hysterical
if that's how tony stark died in end
game
he just survived the snap and he's like
i'm fine
and they just cut him out of bed
two weeks later
just be like he didn't get the vaccine
and then the movie ends
i want to get vaccinated now
yeah that's not how it works that's not
how it works um but yeah i mean uh
that's funny i mean i i think all these
superhero movies are like so simplistic
and it's just like they're just powerful
like
i mean i think that's just what we think
people should be like but i think our
power comes with the group not just
individuals having super powers so you
have an avengers outlook i'm like the
eternals
did you watch the eternals neither have
i it does not interest me at all yeah
it's shitty avengers it's like uh day
soap opera avengers the only reason why
i was gonna watch that was camille
nagioni yeah the comedian that made it
yeah he made it and then he got
re-helped
hurry up
absolutely hurry up in comedy yeah why
do people do that man that's the most
annoying [ __ ] his comedy is hard yeah
but at the same time it's like it's
fulfilling yeah it's like such a
fulfilling feeling and like well i think
you're very honest in comedy and with
acting you can hide and you can just be
like i am this version of me
acting is the opposite of honesty
exactly you're forcing yourself to cry
you don't feel that emotion you just
hate a bagel so if people like you then
it's not really you and if people hate
you it's not really you so you don't
really care but with comedy if they hate
you they're like i hate your brain yeah
the way you have fun yeah i hate the
idea that you come up with every day
your ideas are my least favorite thing
it's just like man i bet if i hung out
with you for like three days i could
make you laugh a lot
that's like the thing i don't understand
like i bet i've said stuff on podcast to
make people offended and that would make
people not like me and [ __ ] like that
but just like spend three days with me
like i don't care if it's like
non-binary i don't care if you're trans
i don't care what you are i will have
fun with you and i'll get you laughing
at the stuff i laugh at because you
realize i'm joking i'm [ __ ] around
that's all i do all we do is [ __ ] around
yeah that's what we're good at is like
talking to people like people are
uh supposed to be
you know like uh good family members or
good friends they're not supposed to be
political machines that have the correct
opinions on everything like our our real
skill is like as human beings is like
getting along with others and being a
part of a family or a friend group or
something yeah we just want to find our
pack yeah we're just looking for
acceptance in any
sort of way that we can get it like
especially us as comedians like we're
just
trying our best to kind of figure out an
avenue or a pathway that we can really
make the most people happy right that's
all it's possible it's our whole job
people tribe could be the whole world
like i know and it has been for people
which is insane it's that because it's
happened so there's stuff that we can
all agree with yeah it's the aspiration
it's like it's there yeah like people
have reached it so it's not impossible
but at the same time it is desperately
each day becoming more and more
impossible it's like we're like becoming
more stratified we're getting angry at
each other and we're less agreeable yeah
it's like charitable it's like
presidents right now comparing
themselves to caesar just being like he
ruled he ruled everywhere it's like well
things have changed well can you be a
comedian that appeals to everyone
without sacrificing your authenticity or
do you have to like pick a lane and be
like i'm just gonna play to
conservatives or liberals i think no i
think there's a way that you can just
talk and have it be authentic with
everybody yeah because they should be
tapping into something deeper than
politics but our humanity we should be
tapping into our humanity and what we
all have in common hopefully yeah and
like the things are that like the most
things that all of us as people have in
common are so prime evil that like it's
completely like it's right there in
front of you but it's like you kind of
have to make it work but don't you think
like a lot of people have used our
primeval
origins and commonness for evil and
instead of like using our positive sides
they tap into our negative sides oh yeah
tons of media corporations and like
companies ad companies are constantly
tapping into the prime evil side of you
trying to sell stuff by just showing you
like [ __ ]
skin it's like human flesh and just
being like you're an ape you want to buy
this
it's like carl's jr has a hot dog in a
burger and it has a pretty lady you want
to buy the meat you want to buy the meat
because the woman's holding it it's like
that that seemed to be like a thing that
was
like relatively
popular back in like the early 2000s
where i was like america [ __ ] yeah but
it seemed like it kind of came with like
a tone of being like we're [ __ ]
around like this
this is no way a serious ideology yeah
this isn't like we're not blatantly like
have this nationalistic attitude where
we're just sitting there like oh yeah
this is uh america's the best and it's
the only country and if you uh get uh
indian food you can [ __ ] kill
yourself because it's not carl's jr like
it's not a hot dog on a burger and fries
it's like all in one sandwich no people
are like it was like kind of leaning
into that standpoint and just being like
this is like no there's no real ideology
to replace that they're like this is a
joke but then what do you do outside of
that joke we know this is not the
correct ideology but then there's no
replacement yeah there's no substance
behind it there's no like actual kind of
like it's just a cupcake with all icing
there's there's no [ __ ] middle
there's no foundation it's just all
fluff
and so like that kind of became like and
then it became like
almost like within that it just became
the exact polar opposite where everyone
has to be the most genuine that they are
at all [ __ ] times you can't say
anything that's a joke everything you
say is truthful and factual it's like it
like humanity works in extremes it's
always you're this or you're that
there's no in between there's no like
middle ground where you could be like oh
i
i don't particularly like chicken
fingers but hey if they're on the menu
and there's nothing else i'll eat them
no you don't like them and you have a
flag for it and you fly that [ __ ]
flag outside your house we're gonna burn
it down like it's
it's insane the like kind of like
tribalistic
avenues that people get themselves into
when in actuality it's just like just
have a [ __ ] conversation about it
people are so easy and so able to shut
people out and just completely just
allow them to be just nothing just be
like just a past memory just like oh i
don't associate with that person anymore
when in actuality it's like you you know
there's still a person right you know
there's still people like in the same
respect of the random people that you
care about on the internet who are going
through like struggles and strifes they
may be going through the same struggles
and stripes not on such a exponential
scale but on a personal scale
like
if someone got killed in [ __ ] ukraine
and like someone got like murdered by
gang violence over here in the united
states do those things not hold the same
comparable weight in someone's heart
they do it's a loss of a life and people
are like oh because it's not a
geopolitical conflict no because it's
like no it's
people need to have more humanity it's
just like understanding that it's not
everything is binary it's not ones and
zeros it's just a completely
spectrumized version of just
life around us
everything it's not just extremes
there's vague middle grounds there's
three and a halfs between the three and
the four that you kind of don't
understand but maybe like
it you don't understand until it happens
to you and it's
it's full of surprises and a lot of
people like nowadays i feel like don't
understand that and it's weird to be
like i'm a young [ __ ] guy i'm 23. i'm
like i'm i don't want to wax
philosophically on any sort of dumb
[ __ ] or like make myself seem like
i'm blowing smoke up my own ass but it's
if i'm understanding this i have my ged
i've just been doing comedy for seven
years how the [ __ ] is no one else
understand it like just be nice
it's like is is it was it my grown-up
environment was i privileged with the
opportunity just to be nice to other
people and just like not have to look
out for myself and only myself because
that was the situation around me or is
it just like i have different wiring
there's so many different components
into it and i'd love to learn more but
college is expensive so i can't so what
do you what is the biggest example of
people not being nice
or not being decent it's just like it
it's comparable day to day it's just
the
the whole
[ __ ] you i'm me and you're you and i'm
living my life type thing so the
selfishness yeah the selfishness like
the oneness you should be more a part of
a collective not a part of a collective
where it's like we all have a hive mind
that we have to work towards cult it's i
just think about other people like
they're you
yeah it's like so where where is where
do you see that manifesting itself
uh mostly like
i mean
specifically around here over the past
couple of days a homeless problem
no one [ __ ] helps them it's like
basically pigeons around here so like
people that are like [ __ ] the homeless
we just gotta nuke them we just gotta
get rid of them or just like not looking
for a direct solution outside of
you doing policing more policing will
solve it yeah it's like you're doing
something why aren't you doing anything
if you have such an issue with it it's
like don't you think that if you gave
say if you walked past a homeless guy
you have all this fun [ __ ] wealth you
live in austin texas the height of music
live music everything's coming here and
it's like you have all this kind of just
collective stuff around you instead of
maybe going get like
like [ __ ] some pokey noodle bowl and
gnocchi
like for lunch that day give twenty
dollars to a [ __ ] homeless guy and
guess what if you keep doing that every
single day it's like not only are you
you're gonna build something around you
people are gonna notice you people are
gonna like you if you just walk by you
know homeless guys like hey how you
doing you give them money and stuff like
that like have a blessed day and if
everyone did that we could really
transfer wealth yeah it's like it feels
[ __ ] good do people not understand
that that feels good
like to give like 20 bucks to a homeless
guy way more than they would expect to
get like but like um don't you think
like people want a more effective
solution than just
uh
giving money to people on the street
because like you don't know if they're
actually homeless you don't know
like if they'll actually use it
correctly like wouldn't it be better if
we had like a more social like a
solution that's more efficiently done
with like the whole society yeah there
would be i mean that's obviously that's
something that is on the grand scale
something that would like to be done
like just to eliminate it ultimately and
altogether
so it's like everyone is better and
stuff like that but
what can you can only do what is
presented in front of you if you have
like
five dollars
in your walking pat
walking past someone and you don't need
it
give it to him it's like you're only
living in the now that's what everyone
is living in everyone is living at the
exact same time that we're living at
right now it's like everywhere it
doesn't change that's never gonna change
so why don't you take the like the first
baby steps in helping and maybe
eventually say you can be the leader of
that project if you really want to put
something together or like start a
non-profit and only come at it from like
a beneficial point of view
but like what is the process that
creates this homeless people because if
we just keep giving money to them like
we're only uh putting a band-aid on it
and the real culprits are getting away
scot-free without having to answer for
creating this homelessness problem yeah
the
the when you have a [ __ ] dead root in
a tree it goes all the way to the top
it's not it doesn't just stop at the
base there's problems all throughout
that need to be solved yeah and that
could be brought to the attention of the
people that are trying to solve them you
could be a local spokesperson for like
the homeless are working at shelters
trying to figure something out and if
that's really like your cause you can
champion it
but it's it's more of just the fact of
like
no matter what it's going to be bad all
throughout the people who are benefiting
off of people losing their homes having
their homes be foreclosed on and being
put in the situation aren't going to
admit that they're benefiting from this
because that's a bad thing that's not a
good person they have to tell themselves
something they have to tell themselves
some way to excuse it in their head and
people are very good at justifying bad
things on their head yeah and it's just
you need to kind of figure out the
avenue and the pathway to
kind of take was not responsibility but
if you're trying to if you're looking
for something to be done to do something
don't wait for other people be the
change it's like it sucks to say it
because it's on like the back of every
[ __ ] third grader's classroom wall
but be the change you want to see in the
[ __ ] world yeah it's like it's it
it's a very small baby step to the
beginning of all that but it it's what
it's all that sometimes all we can do
giving money to homeless is pretty
effective in terms of like transferring
wealth and like
giving them what they need because you
don't need to give them money or you
don't give them like a blanket or a
water bottle you can just give them
money and then they can get it
themselves yeah you can do that or if
you're like worried that they wouldn't
spend the money on the thing that you
would want say if you want them to get
food just go buy the [ __ ] food and
give it to him yeah go buy the food go
buy a drink and it's like people will be
so [ __ ] excited so [ __ ] blessed
but ideally we wouldn't have homeless
people we would pay people fairly we
would have like
services and we'd make sure that people
were able to utilize their full
potential in life oh yeah that's like
what is ultimately work towards and
stuff as a society it's not like
everyone in the it's not like as a hive
mind in the united states all around we
all agree unitedly to give a homeless
person 20 that day and it just solves
the problem overnight it's like it's
gonna take time like in the same respect
that everything takes time it could take
a lot less time if people were like
if like the higher ups within the rotted
root of the tree like [ __ ] kind of
dedicate themselves to figuring it out
and divulging funds that are like trying
to stop people from getting [ __ ]
abortions and [ __ ] like that to actually
helping the people who need need help
yeah it's like how many [ __ ] veterans
who fought for this country end up on
the streets with post-traumatic stress
and nowhere to go and just end up taking
their own [ __ ] life it's like pretty
much a story everyone tells at this
point because it's so common but it
seems so overlooked like it's just like
oh that was before it's like no it's
still happening people are still in that
situation people have just such a quick
like
like who cares [ __ ] them people's minds
are the news where it's just every
single story that changes what was the
last story who gives a [ __ ] we're on to
the new thing and it's like everyone
thinks of that collectively as like and
it's like no all these things that were
still happening the cat that's lost is
still lost
it's like it hasn't been found you have
to like kind of
understand that everything is happening
all the time all at once
yeah i mean we're very distracted and i
think it's on purpose i think people
don't want us to think about the grander
picture no you figure it out because
it's overwhelming yeah it's just i mean
i think we don't treat our workers very
well we don't give them health care we
don't let them unionize we don't give
them fair wages and so we're going to
have more homeless people oh yeah dude
if i was if i wasn't as young as i was i
wouldn't have health care right now i
like i'm on my parents health care until
i'm 26 and then i'm [ __ ] if i don't
have
a way to get health care of my own i'm
gonna have to pay like twelve hundred
dollars if i break like not even that
like twelve thousand dollars so if i
break my [ __ ] arm or like if i have
like some stomach issue going on because
my stomach gets [ __ ] up all the time
and that's how they get you to work yeah
you got to have a job if you want health
care
and it's like it was a compromise it was
like the unions were fighting for health
care and then they were like well we
could either have no health care or
health care tied to our job and then
they tie it to our job it's like you got
to break your back with labor so you can
get help for your broken back from all
the labor yeah it's just they're using
our bodies yeah
and they're not providing us with the
basics that we need and there's always
gonna be underclass that's gonna be uh
[ __ ] up or not as privileged and like
how deep do you want the bottom of this
society to go like we could go all the
way to the bottom where they're homeless
or we could have like a like a bottom
where it's like oh you might be deranged
and mentally unstable but you still have
a home it's like we don't need every
house to be a mar-a-lago that's not what
we need we don't need a pearl aisle down
every street where everyone has a gold
mailbox we just need
a base a good financial stable base
where the bait where the bottom rung is
still doing okay because nowhere in the
world has that wouldn't that be amazing
if just everyone is just like everyone
has a home there's no homeless in
america yeah like we have like dog
shelters or cat shelters like how much
more precious is a human and if we could
have zoos of animals just for people to
look at like why can't we put humans in
homes and i think it's like we don't
even have to give people money for free
all we have to do is pay people fairly
for the work that they do like at
mcdonald's instead of paying them the
minimum amount legally possible give
them the money that they earned that
they brought in for your company and
stop giving everyone the minimum amount
legally
uh allowed and then giving all that
profit to the ceo yeah well all top 40
board people in the mcdonald's company
all got like a solid gold m shaped
helicopter this year for their bonus
like all the people working down at the
bottom actually flipping the [ __ ]
burgers are just
sitting there dick in hand trying to
afford a ps5 for their kids yeah they
got
the least amount possible yeah to pay
someone literally the minimum of wages
yeah and it's not like legal it's not
like they need to get paid a helicopter
for every worker but there needs to be a
middle ground between paying them the
least amount possible and paying them
like 500 million dollars a year i mean
i'm i'm [ __ ] like i'm in the middle
of that [ __ ] i get paid minimum wage
right now i'm working
three jobs including comedy
like i'm doing this i edit a podcast
which i get paid cash for
and like it's just like i can't
i would love to move out here this is a
great opportunity being out here seeing
all you people i don't have the money
for that and that's like what i feel
like a lot of people is lost on it's
like
i've never had ten thousand dollars i've
never had five thousand dollars
in my bank account at all in my entire
life
like my bank it says like the amount of
money i've ever had it's like
18 grand in total since i was 16 and
that's me working throughout my entire
career including comedy checks that i
put in there everything it's just like
it it you just see that and then you're
just like i'm i'm making nothing it's
like i i have nothing like i'm actively
worried every time like now that i'm
getting later in the week and my
paycheck is coming on friday i'm
actively worried every time i swipe my
card for something here that's going to
get [ __ ] declined and i have to call
my mom and ask her to put cash in my
account because it ain't the first time
it's happened yeah like it and i am
luckily lucky and beneficial to have a
parent in the position to give cash to
me and like i have never under like
underestimated that or like undersold it
because i i'm like i i'm very
economically focused trying to make sure
that i don't [ __ ] up any of my money
because that's like something that's
been beaten into me yeah i mean if you
were living in the woods and working as
hard as you do you'd be able to survive
but we have all this technology and all
this efficiency and we're working just
as hard as people in the woods and we
can't survive yeah like all that money
and all that productivity is going
somewhere it's going to the
people at the top instead of like you
should be able to survive doing less
work than you would have to do to
survive in the woods and now we have to
do more and like me i'm waking up at six
o'clock in the morning like 5 30 in the
morning every single day i'm getting
ready i'm like lifting like
25 40 pound boxes and like crates and
trays and [ __ ] like that all day i'm
going home i'm editing and then i'm
going out and doing podcasting and by
the time i'm done with the day it's like
i'm emotionally and physically [ __ ]
tired my brain just to survive just to
survive just to try to do what i want to
do as a career to support everything
around it because comedy ain't paying
the [ __ ] bills it's like i'm i'm just
trying my [ __ ] best and just like and
how much better would you be if you
could focus wholly on what you wanted to
do instead of like oh my distracting
yourself are you kidding me if i could
wake up at nine o'clock every day and
just focus on writing and comedy and
just do just that [ __ ] and just work on
myself i would be a [ __ ] superstar in
my own eyes not even like not even to
everyone else not even to anyone else
just emotionally and physically within
my own happier person i would be so
[ __ ] happy but instead it's like i'm
coming home and my hands are black from
like holding and carrying [ __ ] all day
for the past like [ __ ] six hours i'm
driving around constantly i don't get a
second to sit how much energy and how
much art do we lose forcing everyone to
you know be slaves to the ceos and then
you're expected to just make it
yeah and not have to accommodate it's
like it's not the 90s man it's not that
anymore yeah we don't have a cushy
corporate job where they're gonna give
us a 401k yeah it's like give us
retirement half the people on [ __ ]
tick tock are running their own business
within themselves and it's like that
seems to be expected now from comedians
and content people like you and i to be
your own [ __ ] business to be putting
out this putting out that putting out
all that
i have to like i have to worry about how
many trays i'm delivering tomorrow while
also editing a podcast that isn't even
mine
and like that's the best use for humans
that we have is to carry crates and
trays yeah burgers like we should have
robots do that but as long as it's
cheaper to hire a human for minimum wage
we're never going to make that transfer
it's just like it's just so it's
so aggravating sometimes we're like yeah
i mean like i'll be here and this is the
first time i've ever been here and like
it seems like some people like me here
which i really appreciate
and
they'll come up to me and they're like
you need to move here and i'm like
it's not that simple yeah i think it's
not that simple as like they're like oh
just like just like ditch a girl just
[ __ ] come out here be a solo stud
it's like
i'm not gonna be happy if i do that i
want to be happy wherever i am you're a
human being you have emotional
connections
i love my girlfriend my parents are
moving into [ __ ] new york and that's
where i wanted to go now i'm here and
everything's getting all [ __ ]
convoluted and i'm just like i feel like
i'll do really well here and it wouldn't
be me starting from the beginning like i
would be in new york i would have
somewhat of a platform with tony and
stuff here but it's just
it's just it's all convoluted and it's
easier said than done by
because a lot of a lot of people giving
the advice have just been stuck in it
where they're just like it have been in
that mindset of just having
fine financial wealth for and or being
financially stable yeah wow i'm just
like if i went to the hospital right now
and i didn't have insurance or my
parents i'd be in serious [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's what we do we milk
people for their manual labor and we
waste their actual talents oh yeah it's
a waste of human potential and imagine
all the thousands millions of people in
america that could be producing amazing
[ __ ] that aren't we're just [ __ ] cows
bro milk me yeah milk me i'm a cow
that's what we feel like yes milk me
dude whatever you want as long as you
got a [ __ ] check at the end of it
milk me i don't care so what do you
think about will smith slapping chris
rock and did you see dave chappelle get
tackled i didn't see that i did see that
wait did we take breaks during this no
oh [ __ ] i got a piss so bad um yeah i
mean do i piss my pants
sure
all right what are we doing it's like
the [ __ ] yourself oh yeah to make a
statement i'm gonna pee my pants as a
sign of respect
you're watering this holy chair with
your fluids oh yeah i know i'm making it
real i'm making it real oh god i gotta
be so bad well do you want to end uh in
the podcast how long have we done like
an hour and a half oh [ __ ] i had no clue
one three zero
one thirty one thirty one thirty oh [ __ ]
well what should we end it on well what
do you think about comedians getting
attacked um i think it's
shitty i think it sucks because i feel
like it's going to be transferred along
down the line yeah it's going to
definitely go
man if this translates to bar shows and
phoenix i'm going to be so [ __ ]
pissed we're going to have to take
self-defense classes today yeah if i
have to have if i i thought i was out of
the woods in high school when i was
worried about getting [ __ ] bullied
but i had to worry about it
it's like a slide into subconsciousness
or like not thinking like we don't talk
about things or think about things we
just are animals that are just attacking
we can't talk to each other anymore oh
no it's just all barks everyone is
barking at each other and when one
person barks you bark back because hey
i'm not gonna be the only person barking
it's like it's it's
it's insane everyone has
like constantly going over a fever pitch
and shiningly trying to constantly like
i'm yelling louder no i'm yelling allen
no i'm yelling louder it's like no it's
can we have a conversation yeah we're
slowly losing it yeah the age of debates
are over do you remember when like gnome
chomsky would go and debate people
and [ __ ] like that where it just didn't
turn into just being like you're dumb
and your wife is gay
you're ugly you're ugly and your wife's
a dog your wife's a dog she had sex with
a child
the man has completely ruined that yeah
the time for
public discourse is uh far behind us
yeah that's not rewarded no it's not
it's more like look at this [ __ ] nerd
he didn't say what are those on stage
well do let's just end it and then we
can go pee all right you got a p2 a
little bit yeah oh i got a full dick
dude i'm pulling this
right from your platter into your dick
yeah but um
should i get plugs
yes um
tristan is a comedian on instagram i
have my own podcast the final stop
podcast with me and a bunch of my
phoenix friends it's a lot less serious
than this
it's fun
but honestly yeah this has been a bunch
of [ __ ] fun i've ever haven't really
had a lot of time to like sit down and
talk like introspective with someone and
just like oh i didn't know i wanted to
talk about this
we got to do that i'm uh always looking
forward to these conversations yeah man
let's [ __ ] touch tips in the bathroom
bro i put my penis in your foreskin
tristan check him out i'm hans i'll see
you guys later he's hans i'm tristan bye
you